Die Hochzeitsplanerin und das
künftige Brautpaar in der Hochzeitssuite –
kurz löst sich die Anspannung
der letzten Wochen.
Das Paar will wie viele in Deutschland
im Schloss feiern, im großen Stil:
Alles muss perfekt sein.
12.000 Euro wollen sie für den
großen Tag ausgeben.
Weil man letztlich einmal im Leben
nur heiraten sollte, deswegen …
… wird!
Ja schon, wird auch so sein, ja.
Und da sagen wir uns,
geben wir ein bisschen mehr aus.
Es soll etwas Besonderes sein.
Wir wollen diesen Tag …
uns immer wieder daran zurückerinnern.
Und deswegen haben wir gesagt: Ok, das ist
es wert, mal ein bisschen mehr auszugeben.
Und es soll etwas Unvergleichbares werden.
Es wird ein Feuerwerk geben,
es wird Golf gespielt,
und eine Band darf auch nicht fehlen.
Es muss immer verrückter werden:
wie zum Beispiel, dass man schaut,
wenn man irgendwo unterwegs ist,
dass man den Tag so gestaltet,
dass man immer Abwechslung drin hat.
Ob da ein Comedy-Kellner kommt,
der die Gäste bespaßt,
ob wir einen Karikaturisten haben,
der dann Karikaturen von den Gästen gestaltet,
ob wir irgendwo wild mit dem
Boot und Wasserski fahren, ne?
Das hatten wir letztes Jahr, dass die Gäste
Wasserski fahren konnten –
also all die Dinge,
die zum Spaßbringen beitragen.
Beim Floristen zeigt sich der
Einfluss der sozialen Medien
wie Facebook oder Instagram.
Sie bieten Inspiration,
setzen die Paare aber auch unter Druck,
noch schöner, noch besser als
andere zu sein.
Aufgrund der Social-Media-Kanäle,
die wir heute bedienen,
das muss man ganz klar sagen,
kriegen sie’s ja auch vorgelebt, ne?
Und man will da einfach auch ein
Stück weit mithalten.
Im internationalen Vergleich
rangiert Deutschland
bei den Ausgaben für
professionell geplante Hochzeiten
eher im Mittelfeld.
Hierzulande liegen sie im Schnitt
bei 15.000 Euro.
Zu den Spitzenreitern zählen die
USA mit 30.000 Euro und China.
Dort werden in den Großstädten
locker 42.000 Euro hingeblättert.
Bei den russischen Hochzeiten ist es so,
dass es die ganze Zeit ne Moderation gibt.
Die Gäste werden den ganzen Tag bespaßt,
es fließt viel Alkohol,
das Brautpaar sitzt grundsätzlich
alleine am Tisch.
Das ist ganz anders als bei uns.
Und die türkischen Hochzeiten
sind oft sehr, sehr groß.
Da wird auf Essen überhaupt gar kein Wert
gelegt, sondern es fängt sehr, sehr spät an.
Es wir spät begonnen, es sind meistens
Turnhallen, die da genutzt werden.
Fast jeder neue Lebensabschnitt wird zum
Event, sogar die Scheidung –
was man dem jungen Hochzeitspaar
nicht wünschen will.